la passion qui anime ces marins est la
même que celle qui ronge les amoureux
des vieilles voitures
ils se rassemblent les week end autour
de leur bateau pour discuter techniques
de construction accastillage mature
gréements
[Musique]
il existe un héritage à préserver celui
issu de la pêche et du cabotage de plus
en plus méconnu des plaisanciers
évoluant sur des bateaux modernes aux
coques en plastique
[Musique]
au moins 300 vieux gréements de toutes
origines de tous âges ils étaient tous
là pas au sec dans un musée met à l'eau
et avec équipage s'il vous plaît comme
au bon vieux temps nostalgie oblige
[Musique]
du plus petit moins de cinq mètres au
plus grand plus d'une centaine de mètres
de long ces voiliers vont célébrer
pendant une semaine le patrimoine
maritime européen et qui va revivre à
l'occasion de brest 92
c'est un événement dément des noms de
même pour moi parce que je moi j'adore
le bois est forcément et la marine à
voile
c'est incroyable
[Musique]
le long du fleuve deux millions de
personnes pour une parade d'exception
aux avant postes le trois-mâts norvégien
le stade sera de même cool suivi de près
par le navire école du sultanat dauman
[Musique]
à